hi just wanted to take a minute and
thank everyone who commented on my video
rant about star trek into darkness I
especially want to thank the decent
right thinking people who agreed with me
about what's so very wrong about these
rebooted Star Trek movies as for the
dissenters who disagreed with me you
have not swayed me with your arguments
when a single out cat whelan who wrote
in I hate you you suck you must be
stupid the new Star Trek is awesome you
suck you suck you suck you suck do you
kiss your mother with that mouth oh wait
it's typewritten comments are the
fingers you use to type those comments
the same fingers you use to stroke and
caress your mother well thank you for
the constructive criticism cat I've got
some constructive criticism for you when
you use the letter U instead of the word
y.o.u it really hampers the
effectiveness of your argument also got
a comment from norbert parada that
really stood out to me he wrote nerds
rage over the dumbest things now I know
why this channel is called weird well
Norbert if it's dumb to think that JJ
Abrams should go to jail forever for
what he's done to the legacy of Star
Trek then I guess I'm dumb Gideon wrote
in to say that I should cut JJ Abrams
some slack because there's only so much
he can do in a two-hour film ah no
excuse jail forever anyway thanks for
watching and keep on watching I'm out to
save pop culture for you there's a lot
of stuff I'm angry about
what's getting under your skin make a
video and let me know everyone's got an
angry nerd in them